hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to look at the wolf
language some of you have probably never
even heard of wolf before but it's an
important language of West Africa and
you might even know a little bit of wolf
already
wolf was one of the languages spoken
among African slaves brought to the
Americas and a number of words that are
of possible wool of origin have entered
American English via African American
vernacular English most of them were
introduced into the mainstream through
the popularity of jazz music
they include jive Digg Juke as in
jukebox and hip these words may seem a
bit out of date now but they were very
important words in American culture in
the 20th century the word banana may
also be of wall of origin though it
entered English via Spanish or
Portuguese
Wolof is spoken by at least six million
native speakers the vast majority of
them in Senegal were around 40% of the
population speaks it as a native
language but Wolof is also used as a
lingua franca throughout much of Senegal
so including second language speakers
around 80% of the population can speak
it and I've seen estimates as high as
90% the official language of Senegal is
French not Wolof but Wolfe is the most
widely spoken language it's also spoken
by around 20% of the people in Gambia
including more than half of the people
in the capital city than jewel as well
as around 7% of the people of Mauritania
it's a member of the Senegambia branch
of the niger congo language family which
is also known as the northern atlantic
branch the name wellif means people of
love an area in present-day Senegal
where the jollof Empire also known as
the wolf Empire was established at the
end of the 14th century it's the name of
the wool of ethnic group as well as
their language because most wall of
people converted to Islam in recent
centuries and because of the presence of
Arab traders in the region
wellif contains some Arabic influence
some Arabic loanwords include said I'm a
queen the traditional Islamic greeting
some of the days of the week that
Tuesday from Arabic at the lava lava
Wednesday from Arabic RBR
nice first day from Arabic Alchemist and
ajumma Friday from Arabic l-jamaa last
time or our this is from Arabic walked
or walk - which includes the Arabic
nominative case ending ooh there are
some more words but not that many to be
honest there has also been French
influence on Woollett
that's because Senegal is a former
French colony the French established
trading outposts there beginning in the
17th century and fully conquered Senegal
during the 19th century it remained a
French colonial territory until 1960 the
Dakar variety of wool off' has the most
french influence with numerous French
loanwords the rural varieties of wool
off' are more conservative we'll see
some examples of French loanwords later
some features of Wolof the semi Gambian
languages including Wolof do not have
tones this sets them apart from most of
the Niger Congo language family like
other languages in its family wellif
contains pre nasalized consonants these
are combinations of nasal sounds and
stops which function as individual
consonants like most Niger Congo
languages
Wolof has a system of noun classes
categories of different types of nouns
that are represented by specific
inflections but Wolof is unique in that
the noun itself is not inflected but
rather it's typically the definite
article that is inflected for example
the shirt seam is V the cat moves me the
woman aging G the earth soo see the noun
class inflection can be seen in the
first consonant of the definite article
there are ten noun classes including two
plural classes though I understand that
in urban wool ax b has replaced the
others to a large extent wolf has no
separate grammatical category of
adjectives instead there's a category of
verbs called stative verbs which
indicate states conditions feelings etc
these are used instead of adjectives
Wolof has three sets of personal
pronouns independent pronouns object
pronouns and subject pronouns
independent pronouns are used for
emphasis and to answer questions similar
to the disjunctive pronouns in French
independent pronouns and object pronouns
have
fixed forms but subject pronouns have
many different forms in the wolf verb
system the verb itself is not conjugated
but rather the subject pronoun is
inflected instead the subject pronouns
indicate not only person a number but
can also indicate time normally aspect
rather than tense as well as focus it
can be verb focus object focus or
subject focus there are three types of
verbs in Wolof action verbs identity
verbs and state of verbs which we
mentioned before identity verbs are
verbs that give basic information about
you and your background such as doot to
be named yoga to come from you do to be
born and so on these three types of
verbs are important because they're used
in different verbal constructions
different conjugations if you will all
right let's jump right into some
sentences and see some of these features
in action you can go to do the sentence
means what's your name word for word
it's how you singular named Linda is an
object focus pronoun it's focusing our
attention on the word naka meaning how
so it's often used in asking or
answering questions that identify the
object or compliment this here is the
second person singular object focus
pronoun to be clear there's a full set
of these object focus pronouns for the
various persons and numbers these are
subject pronouns but they have the added
function of telling us to focus on or
emphasize the object this is one set of
subject pronouns with that specific
function but there are numerous other
sets of subject pronouns with different
functions here too is the identity verb
meaning to be from note that this
question is often contracted to know to
do with know being a contraction of naka
and gaw but I gave you the full form to
show how the underlying sentence is
constructed an answer might be good
attitude word-for-word it
goroh that's a name I named in this
reply la is the first person singular
object focus pronoun one thing to note
is that will of typically follows an SVO
word order but in an object focused
sentence with a verb it's osv to give a
greater sense of the object focus maybe
an English
we could translate this as it is gora
that I am called here's another sentence
with object focus simile Galib Duke this
means I love my job or it is my job that
I love maybe you'd say this in response
to a question asking what you love about
your life now let's make this a subject
focus sentence na bakke somebody K this
means I love my job with the emphasis on
the subject I maybe you'd say this if
someone asks who loves their job
overhearing your conversation now let's
make this a verb focus sentence then of
a summary key this means I love my job
with the emphasis on love maybe you say
this in response to someone asking if
you dislike your job notice again that
in the object focus sentence the object
comes at the beginning also remember
that these are subject pronouns which
include the additional meaning of focus
these ones here are only the first
person singular forms which are part of
wider sets of pronouns this form here
indicates verb focus for action verbs
but when it's a state of verb that
functions like an adjective
then this form draws our attention to a
state or condition does it end it's hot
here Tunde is a state of verb meaning to
be hot this construction is often used
to explain a reason or cause let's look
at another sentence meaning dick this
means they're having breakfast this
sentence contains a different kind of
pronoun called a presentative pronoun
these pronouns don't have any focus but
rather indicate an aspect of time they
tell us that some action or condition is
currently true this part here engi on
its own means here like the action or
condition you can see right in front of
you with an action verb this particle II
is added to the end of the pronoun which
makes it like the present continuous in
English but with an identity verb it
tells us something about someone's
current identity even if that part of
the person's identity stems from an
occurrence in the past link buddy I live
in Paris linking like Ithaca I grew up
in Dakar notice that with identity verbs
the e affix is missing from the pronoun
because your identity is not a present
continuous action it's your current
state it's who you are
if you think about the way these
presentative pronouns are used with
identity verbs you can see that they
don't indicate tense but rather aspect
they show that a condition is ongoing
even if it was caused by a past action
another sentence lignin you Latin Union
this means we ate before you arrived
word for word it eat we perfective
before you arrive this verb lekha is an
action verb it's related to the word
lika meaning food which derives from an
arabic word as we saw before this
pronoun nun you is an enunciated pronoun
or a perfective pronoun which shows
completion of the action this is often
used when the simple past or past
perfect would be used in English I
should point out that while wool off' is
generally SVO in perfective sentences
the verb comes at the beginning so this
is VSO the pronoun in de is a neutral
pronoun that contains no time or focus
element in a clause with Latta meaning
before there is no aspect or tense these
neutral pronouns are also used a lot in
speech in which case tense and aspect
are understood from context one thing
that might be confusing here is that
yoga is the same as the second person
singular object focus pronoun which we
saw before I probably should have used a
different one of the neutral pronouns in
this sentence to avoid that confusion
when the perfective is used with the
state of verb it doesn't indicate a past
state it indicates a present state the
perfective indicates that the
development of that state is completed
notice it assumed a body this sentence
means I already have a reservation
word-for-word 'its have i perfective
reservation already note the French word
reservation here you can see that a
present state is expressed by the
perfective form now if we want to
express a past state using a state of
verb we can add a special past marker
not a service on my body this means I
already had a reservation
rather than have a reservation another
sentence hey Luke Dean nu den masa B
this means tomorrow we'll go to the
market word for word it tomorrow we
imperfect go market la in the sentence
we see a different type of subject
pronoun that indicates future well to be
precise
it's the imperfective and indicates that
an action has not been completed yet
here we have the word for market which
comes from the French word marche and
it's followed by the definite article
for its noun class this one starting
with a B the imperfect of pronouns do
not always express future if we add to
them the suffix E which expresses
continuous action that the imperfect of
pronouns indicate a habitual action
which would be expressed with the simple
present tense in English CNN New Eden
Marcy B mezzo Nick
this means we go to the market every day
here we see an imperfect of pronoun with
the prefix e which makes this a habitual
action like we go rather than a future
action like we will go in the phrase
base panic base means day and bunich
means each or every let's look at one
last sentence a ye alone onion Mundi was
done this means the children aren't
sleeping they're chatting word for word
its children the sleep negative they
continuous chat this sentence is about
actions that are in progress right now
so here we see the presentative pronoun
ng which indicates ongoing action that
they are chatting right now closer to
the beginning of the sentence we have
this verb neeli which means sleep with a
negative suffix but no presentative
pronoun this negative suffix indicates
person and number third-person plural
but it doesn't contain any information
about time or focus it's simply negative
this is the normal way of expressing the
negative for all types of verb
constructions so the time and focus
elements are understood from context
here at the beginning we see the phrase
Haleh E which means the children yi is a
definite article for plural nouns
there's one more definite article for
plural nouns me but that one is quite
limited in use these plural articles are
two of the ten definite articles that
are marked for noun class one last thing
to note is the word Rakatan the root of
this word is hua which means to speak
and the suffix tun changes the meaning
to chat and it can also be a noun
meaning conversation or chat but there
are numerous other words built from this
root there is also meaning to have some
speak the causative form Mossad which
means to haggle or to bargain lacet
which means to repeat or restate and
last to which means to talk to yourself
and there's also a homonym of this word
meaning time or hour which comes from
the Arabic word walk do as you can see
wool off' is a very interesting language
and one that might work quite
differently from your native language or
any other language that you've studied
before
perhaps it's standout feature is its
verbal system which makes extensive use
of inflected pronouns which work
together with largely unchangeable verbs
to create a rich system of expression in
this video we merely scratched the
surface and there are more constructions
that indicate different times aspects
and moods and there are additional
features of the language that are beyond
the scope of this video but hopefully it
sparked your interest and you learned
something new the question of the day to
native speakers of Woollett if there are
any of you watching what differences do
you notice between urban Wolof
especially that of Dakar and rural wolf
are they major differences and to anyone
who has visited Senegal or another wool
of speaking area did you learn any Wolof
if so what was your experience if not
were you able to get around using French
or English if you enjoyed this video be
sure to check out lang focus on the
various social media platforms like
Facebook YouTube Twitter and Instagram
and as always I'd like to give a special
thanks to my patreon supporters
especially my talk to your patreon
supporters who you see right here on the
screen many special thanks to them and
to everyone thank you for watching and
have a nice stay